less is more i'd rather have five or six
things on a plate that tastes absolutely
delicious than 10 items tasting average
stuffing for instance
i'd much rather put a lot more effort
into the stuffing
and enjoy it but eat a lot less of it
first add pork mince to the bowl
season with salt and pepper and mix take
your grater
and a bravo an apple
just get the grater
and grate the apple in there
usually stuffing is cooked in the turkey
but i'm doing mine separately so i can
make in advance and get the flavor and
presentation spot on
now the nice thing about the apple
it goes brilliantly well with the pork
it makes it a little bit sweeter
it also makes it a lot lighter as well
which is really important
next add a handful of chopped apricots
which gives the stuffing another fruity
note and a lovely texture the apple
disintegrates but the apricots stay
really nice intact
nice little bite
then chop a handful of pistachio nuts
again
i'm thinking of the build-up of textures
flavor
and also
color
pistachio's in
now give that a really good mix
grating some lemon zest the zest is
packed full of intensely flavored
essential oils which gives the stuffing
a vibrant citrus zing
[Music]
and for freshness add a handful of
coarsely chopped parsley
the balance of flavors
is nice and delicate and it sits
beautifully with a turkey
now
sage and pork and apple that's the
perfect marriage now i'm going to think
about the presentation skills tim full
a little drizzle of olive oil
and then
we get a really nice
fragrant sage leaves
the sage leaves are used to wrap the
stuffing start by overlapping them
it's almost like rolling a cigar but
we're going to roll it
in sage leaves taste is paramount but
presentation is really important too so
it's worth spending a few extra minutes
to get this right because it will make
the final dish look amazing
now a little season
across the top
[Music]
and then
take your sausage meat
and we want to do now is put half it
onto the plate
[Music]
that's what you run your finger
along the stuffing
this is where it takes on a completely
different flavor again i need some spice
in there i want a little bit of heat in
the stuffing so it's exciting to eat
merguez murgays are traditional north
african sausages made from beef or lamb
and all we're going to do now
is take the sausage
and lay that
in the middle they're flavoured with
harissa a fiery chilli paste which gives
them their heat and distinctive colour
it really does give that nice sort of
wake-up call inside the stuffing
if you can't get hold of murgays other
spicy sausages like chorizo would work
well too take the rest of the stuffing
and we'll sit that on top
so in cases
that murgays
[Music]
once you've got it like that
lift up the tinfoil
very carefully
and roll that over
let the temple do the work roll it nice
and tight
there
fingers underneath
[Music]
just pull that back and double check
lovely
look at it it's not even cooked yet and
it looks delicious
the ultimate christmas cracker fantastic
that sage will cook and really perfume
the sausage meat and you cut through to
the center you've got a nice spicy
sausage lovely
in
now
roll it
across
twist at the ends
and then from there
up into the hands
and you push it in
and twist and turn
and all that's doing
is just making the perfect cylinder
beautiful
the stuffing can be made wrapped and
stored in the fridge a day or two in
advance
that's the first part of my ultimate
christmas dinner ready on christmas day
simply pop it into the oven and cook at
200 degrees for 40 minutes
[Music]
apple and cranberry sauce first things
first we're going to make a really nice
caramel
sugar in
add 150 grams of caster sugar to a pan
followed by a couple of star anise
that helps to really
give
a nice sort of aniseed flavor to the
cranberries
next lightly crushed four cardamom pods
this has a lovely warm spicy sweet
flavor
then wait for the sugar to melt and form
a caramel
really important to have the confidence
now to colour that caramel so it gets
really nice and dark before putting the
cranberries in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
the smell of that caramel is amazing now
cranberries in
[Music]
crammies are very tired and acidic but
balanced with the sweetness of the
caramel and apples they give the sauce a
lovely dry sharp note to tell if they're
fresh drop them on a hard surface the
higher they bounce the fresher they are
the secret now
is sort of caramel to blister
the cranberries and really start to
break that down
smells fantastic
next core peel and thinly slice two
apples
and once this sauce is finished it
really does help to sort of wake up
the flavor of the turkey now the
cranberries are starting to break down
apple in
smells fantastic
a touch of salt and pepper that's really
important really helps to balance that
tartness against the acidity of the
apple salt pepper really brings it back
the smell is fantastic it's a sort of
sweet sour spicy nice
now from there
delays the pan with a touch of port
around the side
deglazing dissolves all the lovely
sticky caramelised bits of food that are
stuck to the pan and incorporates them
into the sauce
next add the zest of an orange
and for another layer of fragrant
sweetness squeezing the juice
lovely
then cook on a low heat for five to ten
minutes to thicken but remember the
sauce will become even thicker once it's
cooled down now that
is the right texture i don't want a
runny sauce i want something really nice
and thick delicious
packed full of flavor
perfect
if you really want to get ahead this
sauce can be made three or four days in
advance and kept in the fridge which
allows the flavors to develop even more
[Music]
another job done leaving you more time
to enjoy this very special day
[Music]
and brussels sprouts are delicious when
they cook perfectly packed with texture
and the flavor is extraordinary
take off the outer leaves trim the
bottom and cut in half
that's a big step up from the crisscross
on the bottom that my mother used to do
every christmas
i'm cutting them in half so when i soda
them they cook evenly
and look
it's like little baby cabbages it's so
compact
then blanch them in salted boiling water
for two
minutes now
this is the most amazing pancetta
lightly cured
pancetta is a type of italian bacon
which is brilliant for adding a lovely
rich meaty flavor to dishes i want a
really nice robust flavor
to go with that earthy texture
of the sprout
it's made from pork belly and is dry
cured with salt and aromatics like
juniper bay leaves nutmeg dry thyme and
garlic as it hits the pan that fat on
top of the pancetta melts
and gives the sprouts this amazing
flavor after removing the skin cut into
small chunks
if you can't get hold of pancetta smoked
streaky bacon is a good alternative
now hot pan
a teaspoon
of olive oil
[Music]
give it a nice seasoning with salt and
pepper
as the lavender start to crisp up
take your sprouts
out
drain them
[Music]
sprouts in
now give that a really nice little toss
then chop up a handful of chestnuts
now the chestnut has sweetened the
flavor of the sprout
really important that you don't put the
chestnuts in too early otherwise they'll
go mush
and then just sprinkle
the chestnuts
over
lovely
so we've managed to turn a sort of plain
jane sprout
into something quite
delicious you've got the texture of the
smoked bacon the sauteed sprout
and that nice crunch
and sweetness of the festive chestnut
ten seconds before they come out lemon
zest
over
now that makes the sprouts and the bacon
harmonize
and then just to squeeze
our fresh lemon juice over the sprouts
beautiful
this right now is the ultimate
and for me that's a really nice modern
21st century
approach
to cooking an old-fashioned vegetable
you